we're back with a fox news alert
president biden comparing the ukrainian
border crisis to ours at the southern
border listen to this
the fact that you have
so many so many ukrainians seeking
refuge in in this in this country of
poland
we understand that because we have
in our southern border
thousands of people a day
literally not figuratively trying to get
in the united states but we believe that
we the united states
should do our part relative to
ukraine as well by opening our borders
to another hundred thousand
people
more than three million refugees have
already escaped ukraine with 2 million
seeking asylum in poland
meantime the crisis at our southern
border could get worse next week when a
trump era policy ends sending as many as
and seventy thousand refugees to our
ports of entry i i i'm i'm going
ballistic over the comment of the
comparison
of a war in ukraine mr joey and the
southern border do you see that same
comparison articulated by the guy who's
who is our president you see the
comparison
listen leo it's been it's been a heck of
a week i mean if this were after a
little bit later in the evening i'll
probably use a different word to
describe it i mean i mean it really has
in
you know it's funny in one hand but it's
also absolutely tragic in another i mean
this is the person we need to lead our
country i mean kamala harris goes over
there makes an absolute full of us we
hope the president goes over there with
a lot of prep knowing what had just
happened and instead we have a couple of
days where almost everything he said the
white house has had to fix correct or
pull back on and now we're looking at
the one domestic policy americans care a
lot about and he can't get that right
either he can't talk about it in any way
that people understand what we have in
our southern border are a lot of people
trying to take advantage of the
prosperity of our country and the
weakness of our border what they have at
the polish border are people literally
running for their lives not running for
a better life running to be alive and
that's the problem
and katie
title 42 will expire march 30th that
trump policy that kept people outside
the country and a holy tank they're
counting down the days
between now and march 30th in order to
come across the border what impact do
you see on this happening
well we're going to need words worse
than catastrophic to describe what's
about to happen they're thinking 8 000
illegal immigrants every day will start
crossing after title 42 is taken off and
the comments and the comparison made by
president biden are absolutely asinine
what's happening at the southern border
is a result of open border policies and
multi-billion dollar criminal
enterprises making billions of dollars
off of human trafficking as a result of
bad policy decisions that could be
changed it's completely predictable the
byte administration is enabling it they
haven't changed any of their policies
despite low morale among border patrol
and they haven't changed their
perspective despite the fact that border
patrol agents are seeing violent
criminals with convicted convictions of
sex offending murder coming back and
forth into the country and then going
into the communities that we see all
around america and yet they haven't
changed this there's no comparison they
could stop this tomorrow and instead
they are choosing to enable it
concur 100
jackie
looking to your crystal ball it's
november uh of 2022
joe biden is trying to conflate
the the the plight of the ukrainian
people with the southern border you got
as
katie said you got gang members coming
up coming across the border the american
public might be sympathetic to the
ukrainian people you think the american
people are going to be sympathetic to
those crossing the southern border
illegally when it comes to the midterms
absolutely not and i think it's actually
preposterous what he's doing in making
that comparison it's not to say that
there aren't some people coming across
the border that are facing certain
hardships but to compare them to the
refugees in poland that literally are
having their cities
bombed and shelled
that have been forced to flee is a
completely different story and again we
talk about words matter analogies matter
this is our commander in chief and and
the one thing that i will say is he
doesn't say anything about the border so
at least he actually acknowledged here
that he understands that thousands of
people are coming across the border
every day that's the most i've heard
from him on this issue but making that
analogy is is absolutely wrong and to
your question on the midterms i think
people are watching all of this play out
i think they're watching uh the border
crisis the crisis in ukraine they're
feeling inflation all of these issues
that we're feeling um in our country and
across the globe and and it's it's going
to come out in the polls
i agree joe biden on your way to
washington make a pit stop to the
southern border because you need to
check our border first it's just it's
just maddening and it's just
insulting the intelligence of the
american public hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else